(upbeat music)
- I don't know if you guys noticed,
but my hair has gotten
a little crazy recently.
This is the biggest my
Jew fro has ever been.
I mean really, it's about
to have its own Bar Mitzvah.
("Hava Nagila")
But seriously, it's really annoying.
Every time my hair gets long,
I don't know what to do with it.
I try and wet it, I try and brush it,
and no matter what, it
still looks like this.
I've tried everything and
I thought, you know what?
Maybe I'm overthinking it.
Maybe my hair is not that bad.
So I'm gonna go ask my friends
what they really think about my hair.
- You got hair up there and
sure enough, it's on your head.
- It's kind of smushed right here.
Is that intentional?
- [Eric] No.
- It's all right, man, it's you, own it.
- I kind of like it, I
think you should keep it.
- I like the way that it shakes
when you speak like that.
I think that just gives me something
to distract me from looking at your face.
- So it seems like my hair
has a lot of mixed reviews.
It's like the movie La La Land.
So here's what I'm thinking.
A lot of people with curly hair
get their hair straightened
and it looks great, so I'm
gonna straighten my hair.
It's gonna be amazing, I'm gonna look like
a sexy Game of Thrones character.
Or like an intense, beautiful
viking with luscious hair.
Let's go straighten my hair.
I need your help, all right,
I'm straightening my hair.
- What's up?
- What do I do?
- You're not asking me this.
Do I look like I freaking
straighten my hair, man?
Get out of here, Eric, go somewhere.
Go somewhere.
- Sarah?
- Oh Jesus, hey.
- I'm trying to straighten my hair.
Do you think that's a good idea?
- I don't think it's gonna look good.
- No?
- [Sarah] Hal doesn't
think it's a good idea.
- I think you should just cut your hair.
- Where do I get a straightener?
- (beep) is right across the street,
so they have good straighteners.
Get some heat protectant spray.
- So hair straightening is dangerous?
- I think it will be dangerous for you
but for the average
person, it's not dangerous.
- I went outside, swiped
my curls, and walked in.
There was a lot of stuff in there,
I was very disoriented, it was scary,
I mean, just so many things.
I didn't know where the
straighteners were, but
at least they had some good music.
(upbeat music)
I finally found the hot straighteners and
they were $249.
I just spend $300 at (beep)
so I better look (beep)ing
amazing at the end of this video.
Bye bye, curls.
All right, so I got the stuff.
So the first thing I gotta do
is spray this spray stuff.
It's supposed to protect your hair.
I don't wanna ruin my hair,
I don't want it to catch on fire.
Ooh, bro wow, that is refreshing.
Wow, how much do I put in?
I don't know, I guess I'm just
gonna drench my hair in it.
(upbeat music)
How much do I put in?
My boss just said you
don't even need this stuff.
But I wanna protect my hair, whatever,
I put in a little bit.
Smells great, let's see.
Ooh, fancy, fancy, this was
so expensive, it better work.
Ba-boom.
Wow.
Dude, this looks like
the future right here.
It is gorgeous, though,
look at this design.
Smells clean.
Nice and white ceramic.
You wanna straighten you hair
but you also wanna play music?
There's a little on button right in here.
Hal, I am, I just need help,
some serious help.
I'm trying to straighten my hair,
and I can't even turn on
the hair straightener.
- I don't understand how you got a job.
- All right, so thanks to Hal,
the thing is now on and it is time
for me to straighten my hair.
My hair is so hot.
I spent 30 minutes trying
to straighten my hair,
but my curls are feisty,
so I had to bring in some help.
My friend Ashley straightens
her hair every morning,
so I thought she'd be good for the job.
After about 45 minutes, my hair finally
started to get straight.
It was time for me to see my new hair.
(both laugh)
Literally, I had so much
hope that I would be sexy.
I look like I'm wearing a wig.
All right, let's go see what people think.
Close your eyes and then I
want 100% honest feedback.
- Okay.
Ooh.
- Three, two, one.
(laughs)
- Oh my God.
- Sorry.
- What the (beep)?
- Oh no.
- No?
(laughs)
- It looks like you're about to get
shoved into a locker, but a nice locker,
a locker into Narnia.
- Aw, you look like my guinea pig.
- You look like a
character from Riverdale.
- What's a line from Riverdale?
She died.
- Doesn't he look like
Katt Williams with the--
(all laugh)
- Katt Williams?
- I could see it, Brenda.
He really does look like Katt Williams.
- I think so.
- He straightened his hair,
put the part straight down the middle.
Please do a side by side comparison.
- [Eric] As the day went on,
my hair got pretty crazy.
I think I joined a band.
- I mean, I think you should just go back
to the way it was before.
It looked fine, I don't know why
you're doing all this stuff.
- Kyle was right, so
I jumped in the shower
and got my curls back.
Feels so good to have my curls back.
This experience taught me to just love
whatever makes me different.
My curly hair, it stands out, but it's me.
I'm the crazy kid with crazy hair.
You should always embrace the things
that make you unique, and if
you wanna try something new,
don't be scared because
nothing bad's gonna happen.
Maybe your friends will laugh at you,
but that's just 'cause
they're being honest.
They'll never judge you, though.
I'm glad I tried straight hair,
but I like my curls and
I'm gonna keep them.
(upbeat music)
I should probably get a haircut though.